Let's pray together over day 27, Holiness is something to be
followed from Hebrews 12:14.
Father, we thank you today for the privilege that it is to be called
to holiness,
called to be one with your essential nature,
the core of your being. You have not chosen to give to us
your presence everywhere or your infinite
knowledge, but you have chosen to give to us
the holiness that we need,
and we wish to be there in your presence to see the Lord someday.
So we pray for the grace to follow that holiness and to pursue
after it. Thank you, Lord, that you have given us a
relationship with you that grows and increases.
So Lord, we choose to follow today. We choose to make progress.
We choose to
increase our desire for holiness.
And Lord, we pray that you would help us as we've been learning over the last
few days what it means to be holy
and what holiness in the scripture means, even for those who have already been
saved. And we pray that you would increase our desire for
all that holiness means, for all that holiness is.
Lord, give us a deep and passionate and lasting
desire for the things of God to reproduce
your character inside us. Lord, cleanse from our heart, put
to death within us anything that is not
like Jesus, anything that is not like you.
Lord, if it costs us friends,
if it costs us comfort or ease, or if it costs us our
will and our way, we pray that you would take those
things. They are nothing. They are worth nothing compared to the
joy of knowing your holiness. Lord, we want to die to
self and die to idols in such a way that we are able to
live in full harmony with and follow deeper and
deeper the holiness of God until someday we follow it
right through the gates of heaven.
We pray that you would give us a passionate commitment to
this path of holy love and holy joys in Jesus'
name.
Let's continue seeking the Lord and praying together.